While it's tempting to respond to the input event inside of the event hamper,
it's generally considered bad practice to do that. Now to get a better
understanding of that, let's look at this representation of a frame over time.
Our green boxes represent the update of individual items that exist. And the
red boxes represent the rendering of those items. Now, let's say, for instance,
the user hits their keyboard which would move the player around. And, let's
say, that our engine actually gets that call back right here. So, our updating
of the player in a specific position has already occurred, including physic
engine processing and everything else. While our rendering will now be pulling
data for a new position in the environment. Now what this particular instance
can lead to is an interesting phenomena. This makes a disjoint correlation
between our update loop and our render loop. We can actually be updating our
environment with the player at this position. Yet rendering with the player at
this new position. Now while all this may seem minute in a 30-frames or
60-frames per second environment. Things get a little cooky once you start
factoring in network physics which hopefully we'll cover a little bit later. In
practice the events come out a little bit like this. So, let's say we have a
timeline of events that are going to be passed into our application. In a
timeline that represents our update loop. Now what occurs is that we're not
really sure when the events are going to come to us from the browser. They can
occur
[SOUND]
pretty much any time
they want. Now, what happens is, if we respond to them in turn, we're not
going to have the ability for our update system, or rather, our game code, to
properly be able to react to them. And so what we do is actually store the
input event data inside of our input manager. So that the update loop, or game
code, can query it whenever it wants.